- So we have to talk
about your fur babies.
I just met, you said it's Frankie, right?
- Frankie.
I'm gonna go get him for you.
Frankie, come here, come say hi.
- I was like, I met him before
the interview and I just...
He's so cute, he should be on camera.
- He is the cutest.
Frankie, say hi.
Hi, Frankie.
- Oh my goodness.
Look at it.
He's got a little floppy ear
- He looks like a baby-
right here.
- Aww!
You've kind of become famous with this dog
because we see pictures
of y'all everywhere.
So is that for The Shelter
Pet Project that you do?
- Exactly, yeah.
So I've rescued both Frankie
and his older brother, Chance.
And so I do a lot of work
with The Shelter Pet Project,
which is also with The Humane Society
and Maddie's Fund and the Ad Council.
And we try to get the word out
that shelter pets are awesome
so that people aren't
always going to breeders
and to pet stores and
that they're, you know,
we're trying to change the
stigma of what a shelter pet is.
- Yeah.
Do you think songs to them?
'cause you said you're not a singer,
but I heard you sing to them.
- I do sing songs.
Because you know, like I do the...
I do my, let me see, I'm gonna get,
I'll tell you my Frankie one.
Well, Chance, if I can get Chance.
Come here, Chance!
- Oh my God!
- You're like Houdini.
You just appeared in
another door. (laughs)
- Wait here, I'm gonna say hi to Chance.
Chance!
- Oh, King Charles cavalier?
Is that?
- Yeah.
- He's a rescue too,
and that was actually what I was gonna say
is that, you know, people
think that a lot of times
that shelter pets are...
you know, they're like,
oh, I really wanna get this certain breed,
or I really want like, you know,
and he's, he was rescued
from a puppy mill.
And so he's so purebred.
- Oh, wow!
So Chance, I have a song
for him, and it goes,
- [Kelly] Okay.
- My name is Chance, boom, boom.
Boom ba-dum, my name
is Chance, boom, boom.
Boom, ba-dum, ba-dum ba. (huffs)
'Cause even in the middle of
his own song, he gets tired.
Frankie's is good.
- In his own song,
- he's like this is taking forever.
- [Olivia] Okay, here, yeah.
This is Frankie, 'cause
he got that floppy ear.
- Yes.
- Goes like this.
Like that, ready?
Flop. Wait, ready?
Flop, flop, floppy ears,
I got some flop, flop, floppy ears.
What? Flop, flop.
Floppy ears, we got some
flop, flop, floppy ears.
Okay now.
Flop, flop, flippy flop,
Frankie, flop the flop.
That's it.
- Oh my God!
- I love you so much! (laughs)
- Yeah, I have another one, too,
I just wanna sing, just 'cause I love it.
It goes.
- I love it!
I'm loving all the beats.
- Flop, flop, flop, flop.
- Work it out, work it out,
work it out, work it out.
Flop, flop, flop,
work it out, work it out,
work it out, work it out.
Just, just flop it up, Frankie.
Just, just flop it up Frankie!
- I love it!
- Anyways.
I wish, this is the time I
wish pets could talk. (laughs)
- [Olivia] I know!
- If they were like, they were like,
"Yeah, sing it, girl!"
Or they're like, "She's doing it again."
- Or they're like,
"Oh, if she could only hear
the songs we sing about her."
- Yeah, those are the ones, yeah.
"Secret Life of Pets."
Those movies are so great for kids.
So all this work with
animals has inspired you
to start working with
a new charity, right?
Tell me what you're doing.
- Yeah.
So there's this charity
called Stay Home and Foster.
And you know, they've already
been doing a great job
of trying to get people to foster animals.
And it really was important
when COVID happened
and the lockdown happened.
And when that happened,
a lot of shelters were
having to euthanize animals
because they couldn't take care of them.
And also at the same time,
people needed animals in
their lives, you know,
as you know, like, you know,
it does something different
for you and your kids
like when you have an animal there
and especially with,
- Like a companion.
they have no idea what's
going on in the home, right?
- Yeah, a companion, yeah.
- Yeah, and so I partnered with
Stay Home and Foster myself
and Wag and to promote this cause
and this initiative for them,
and it was so great because
we had 85,000 people sign up
in just such a short period of time
to foster pets across our country.
And it really showed us that, you know,
there was a really big need for fostering
and for us to create
something even bigger,
something that's more evergreen
that really connects
everything that people,
you know, will need when it
comes to like whether it's,
you know, getting more advice
on how to train your dogs
and where to, you know,
find a dog and which shelter
or rescue place you can trust, so.
With Stay Home and Foster,
we are actually doing
this next phase of it now,
which we're really excited about,
which is called Fido
Foster or Feline Foster,
and basically, we're trying
to create a community
that connects all the
shelters in our country
and be one place that people can go to
to go like I want to find one.
- I have said this to people!
You have?
- Because like-
- Yes!
Because I'm like, even how you said,
like when people want
something specific like,
oh, I got this dog 'cause I wanted this,
that dog probably exists,
it's just in Wisconsin and you don't know!
Like, you know?
- Yeah!
So I have said this!
This is such a great idea!
- Yeah.
I mean, you need somewhere
that you can, you can trust.
And it's also somewhere that goes beyond
just giving you the dog,
it's, you know, anything with nutrition,
actually right now, since the
beginning COVID I was like,
man, I gotta do something with my time,
and I didn't feel like writing scripts
like everybody was doing,
and they're like, we're gonna
come out with eight scripts,
and I was like, I can't.
But what I got into was getting
my pet nutritionist license on online.
- I love that!
- From the...
- I know, it's been really great.
And so things like with
Feline and Fido Foster,
you know, you can go on and say like,
what are the things that we
shouldn't be giving our dogs
and what are the things that
we should be giving them?
So, yeah, so with Fido and Feline Foster,
we are trying to create
a real strong community
that will last, you know,
and that is somewhere
that everybody can trust
and go and be able to help save
these animals and, you know,
and add a little furry
friend to their family.
- Yeah, 'cause it...
I mean, it's life-changing.
When it, I mean, just my
kids with my dog, Henry,
like they love Henry.
It's such a security blanket.
It's such a friend.
Like it's all these things.
It's a great when animals do
for households, I believe.
But.
- Yeah.